Bitte schön.
Hallo Guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Ich bin Züchterin der Erste Für Sie.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, Hauptsache jemand hilft mir.
Ja, so heißt für dich ein paar Fragen.
So ihr werdet per durchstellen.
Wie heißt sie denn?
Ich heiße Eva Haas.
Können Sie bitte mir Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen wuschen?
Der Vorname ist Eva E-V-A.
Da geht es gar nicht.
Und Haas ist der Familie Name Haa-A-S.
Ja Frau Haas, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 49 Jahre.
Wann sind Sie je nah geboren?
Am 9.04.74.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 75.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
80 Kilo.
Danke für die Informationen.
Was für die Säure, was für mich werden Sie?
Ich habe seit gestern solche heftigen Rhythmenschmerzen.
Das schießt so ein in den unteren Rücken.
Es geht am rechten Oberschenkel außen runter.
Es geht bis zum kleinen See unten hin.
Das sind sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ich habe im Garten gearbeitet.
Dann habe ich einen schweren Topf von einer Seite zu anderen gestellt.
Da ist es mir reingefahren.
Ich kann mich kaum rühren.
Ich habe heute Nacht ganz schlecht geschlafen.
Ich konnte nicht liegen.
Das Schlimmste war, wenn ich meine Position ändern wollte.
Ich konnte mich kaum rühren.
Ich habe immer erst überlegt,
ob ich das Bein nehme.
Es geht überhaupt nicht.
Wo sind die Genarschmeisen?
Sie haben schon Rhythmen gesagt.
Es geht in den rechten Oberschenkel rein.
Dann habe ich ein unangenehmes Gefühl,
das ganze rechte Bein runter zu kommen.
Können Sie mit dem Bein hier die Schmeisen genau beschreiben?
Siehst Sie, du drückend sehend?
Ich würde eher sagen, ziehend stechend.
Je mehr ich mich bewege, desto schlimmer wird es.
Wenn ich still liege, geht es.
Aber sobald ich versuche, die Position zu ändern,
dann geht es nicht.
Wie ich die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz,
wie ich sie sehe, vorbei, in Nullkeit,
siehst Sie, sie ist sehr stark.
Da würde ich schon sagen, die sind bei 8.
Sie sind wirklich so nett.
Sie haben sehr stark die Schmerzen.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen aushalten?
Wenn ich mich nicht bewege, geht es.
Wenn ich das rechte Bein hochlegen kann,
dann kann ich es wohl aushalten.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Ich will das auch noch mal.
Ich habe noch ein paar Profen.
Ich hatte eine Profen.
Das habe ich genommen.
Aber ich kann nicht behaupten, dass das etwas geholfen hat.
Dann habe ich versucht, mit Wärme ein bisschen draufzugehen.
Das hat für den Moment ein bisschen etwas gemacht.
Aber eigentlich sind es immer noch
unglaubliche Schmerzen.
Okay.
Wie viele Tabletten haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich habe eine Nacht 600er eingenommen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann über einen.
Ich habe heute Morgen noch mal einigen.
Okay.
Aber es hat ihnen nicht geholfen.
Ja, ich habe heute Nacht fast nicht geschlafen.
Ich würde behaupten.
Hatte Sie solche Beschwerden früher?
Oder ist das erstes Mal?
Leichter Form hatte ich schon einmal.
Wenn ich viel gebückt gearbeitet habe,
oder wenn ich schwer gehoben habe,
dann habe ich das schon einmal gehabt.
Aber noch nie so heftig.
Okay.
Sie haben schon erwähnt,
dass die Schmerzen unter rechten Oberschärkern ausschütter sind.
Ja, also in die Poebacken rein.
Und dann geht es so seitlich am Bein runter.
Am Bein runter?
Okay.
Haben Sie an der Beine Schwellung oder Farbeveränderung
gemerkt?
Spellung habe ich dann nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe das nicht bemerkt.
Das habe ich gemerkt, dass das ein bisschen kribbelt.
Dass ich ein bisschen Taubweißgefühle habe.
Okay.
Ja, haben Sie kribbelt nur am Oberschenken?
Oder gar nicht?
Nein, ich kribbelte es vor allem.
Kleines? Ja.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen kribbelt.
Ich habe das nicht bemerkt.
Aber ich kribbelte es vor allem.
Kleines, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Oberschärkern Schwellung
gemerkt an der Beine?
Am Bein? Ja, das sage ich ja gerade.
Dass ich das so ein Taubweißgefühl habe
auf der rechten Seite.
Außen entlang am ganzen Bein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fiber, Frau Hart?
Hab ich jetzt nicht gemessen, glaube ich,
aber nein, ich fühle mich nicht sehr gut.
Leiden Sie unter Schiffdorfrost
Schweißauswürsche oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein, nein, so etwas habe ich nicht.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, also, wenn es so richtig schlimm ist,
dann habe ich schon das Gefühl,
dass mir ein bisschen schlecht ist vor Schmerzen.
Und ich habe jetzt heute auch, weil ich mich so schlecht fühle,
habe ich auch wenig gegessen.
Ich würde jetzt sagen, ich fühle mich eingeschränkt.
Aber dass mir jetzt so vom Magen her
ganz doll übel ist, würde ich nicht sagen.
Aber ich fühle mich nicht fit.
Ja, ich habe gestanden.
Ich habe gestanden.
Haben Sie Fein-Eindringen bei Wasserlassen,
wenn man so Beispiel haben Sie Schmerzen
oder bei Wasserlassen?
Beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das Einzige ist, wenn ich auf die Toilette muss,
dass mir der Rücken weh tut, ja?
Weil ich wieder irgendwie aufstehen muss
und dann habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ich das nicht mehr kann.
Ja, gut, okay.
Okay, haben Sie auch Probleme bei Stuhlgang?
Haben Sie Durchfallverstöpung oder ganz normal?
Nein, also, also,
alles ist eigentlich alles ganz normal.
Ich habe nur diese verrückten Rücken-Schmerzen.
Also ich habe immer Leuchten.
Ich habe immer die Sachen essen, ja?
Dann kriege ich Blähungen und so.
Ich muss also immer mein Gemüse und Obst
eher gekocht essen.
Also Komfort und Apfelmus und so was, das geht alles.
Oder Apfelkuchen.
Aber wo ist Obst, kann ich nicht gut vertragen.
Und wo ist Gemüse schon gar nicht.
Ja, ich war Ihnen eine Raktus
und das habe ich noch nie festgestellt.
Ich habe nur Blähungen, wenn ich Rosenzeug esse.
Okay, okay.
Wie ist Ihre Petit, Frau Haas?
Mein Appetit, ja, also normalerweise ist er gut.
Aber jetzt, heute bin ich einfach ein bisschen
eingeschränkt durch die Schmerzen, ne?
Okay, okay.
Heute habe ich jetzt noch nicht viel gegessen.
Haben Sie in der letzten Saison ab oder Siegernum?
Nein, leider nicht abgenommen, nein.
Okay, okay.
Frau Haas, ich hätte dich einfach fragen,
so wie der Geschichte. Leiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel Bluthoff zurück.
Ja, ich kann gleich eine ganze Menge bieten.
Also ich habe seit Kindheit schon, habe ich
ein Diabetes, das hat man relativ früh festgestellt.
Und da muss ich auch regelmäßig Insulin spritzen, ne?
Okay.
Da habe ich ein Schema und ja.
Ja, okay, okay.
Und dann hat man vor ein paar Jahren mal festgestellt,
dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe
und dass ich auch so erhöhte Blutfettwerte habe, ja.
Na gut, ja, dann nehme ich halt Tabletten.
Da kommt dann auch nicht mehr drauf an, ja.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Ja, das ist so, da sind Sie mich überlegen.
Ja, so vor sieben Jahren hat man das festgestellt.
Und seit wann haben Sie erhöhte Polistinwerte?
Ja, das hat man im gleichen Zusammenhang,
hat man das festgestellt, ja.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie die gärmes Medikamente ein.
Das ist eine ähzylische Pläste.
Ja, also ich nehme noch Mikardis.
Mikardis Plus ist das, das ist,
dann nehme ich morgens und abends eine.
Und dann wegen der Blutfette
nehme ich noch Atorastatin ein.
Dann nehme ich abends eine Tablette.
Okay, wisst ihr Sie die Dosierung von Medikamente?
Also bei Atorastatin,
da steht mal nicht 10 drauf.
Okay, und Mikardis?
Mikardis, das heißt Mikardis Plus,
weiß ich jetzt gar nicht so genau, wie viel da drin ist.
Da müsste ich mal zu Hause anrufen und nachfragen,
was da auf der Paprika drauf steht.
Ja, okay, danke, alles klar.
Und äh, wie viel Öl nehmen Sie in Stübe?
Aus Schippsitz?
Ja, also äh, da, da habe ich 15 Einheiten.
Für Sie. Okay.
Okay, alles klar.
Äh, wann war Ihre letzte äh, äh, Blutsucker-Messung?
Oh, das ist jetzt, ähm, na, eine gute Woche her,
würde ich sagen, 14 Tage her.
Bis die nächste, okay.
Ist, da ist Ihre Blutsucker-Messung,
gut eingestellt.
Ja, okay, alles klar.
Äh, wurde Sie schon einmal opuliert?
Ja, vor zwei Jahren, da hatte ich äh,
eine Kniegeschichte, ja, eigentlich eine Kleinigkeit,
da hatte ich ein Schleinbautel im rechten Knie
und das ist operiert worden.
Mhm, Schleinbautel.
Und da, da, das war ein bisschen dramatisch,
da hat man nämlich festgestellt,
ich habe dann, ich habe dann äh, äh,
Äh, Antibiotika bekommen,
äh, im Rahmen dieser OP
und äh, da habe ich äh, äh, äh, allergisch reagiert
auf Amoxicillin.
Das darf ich also nicht nehmen, da.
Ja, da, äh, hatte ich einen anaphylaktischen Schock
und äh, da hat man mich dann gewarnt,
dass ich das bloß nicht wieder nehmen darf.
Mhm. Okay.
Das ist eine Witte in Formationen.
Auf jeden Fall äh, achte wir
im Krankenhaus darauf.
Machen sich keine Sorge.
Mhm. Okay.
Äh, äh, habe sie noch eine Operation oder das war es?
Das war es eigentlich ja.
Mhm. Okay.
Äh, und Allergie, ist Ihnen noch eine Allergie in Becker?
Ja, ich habe noch so ne, so ne äh,
Polenallergie auf Haselnusspolen.
Mhm. Also im Frühjahr, wenn das früh losgeht
mit, mit der Haselnussblüte,
dann, dann äh, bin ich mit Schnupfen beschäftigt
und habe ich Juckreiz im Gesicht und in den Augen und so.
Mhm. Okay.
Mhm.
Okay.
Äh, Frau Haas, wann war ihr des der Budutu?
Monas Budutu?
Um, ja, das ist jetzt vor zweieinhalb Wochen gewesen.
So, halb Wochen.
Okay.
Ist es möglich, dass sie, sie, okay, alles klar.
Äh, waren Sie schon in der Liste seit niemals, war es?
Hatten Sie eine? Nein, nein, Urlaub waren wir nicht im Aussagen.
Mhm. Okay.
Rauchen Sie, Frau Haas.
Ach, eigentlich rauche ich so gut wie nicht, das kann man fast nicht zählen.
Mhm.
Ich rauche immer nur so zwei, drei Zigaretten am Tag,
das ist eigentlich nur so zur Gesellschaft.
Mhm.
Könnte ich eigentlich auch sein lassen, ne?
Ja, ja, genau.
Äh, weit wann rauchen Sie?
Ja.
Seit ich bei dieser Arbeitsstelle bin, das ist ja schon 15 Jahre.
Mhm.
Weil es für zehn Jahre war.
Mhm. Ein Verstärkung, okay.
Äh, die Linke ist der Alkohol?
Ja, meistens trinke ich abends so ein Glas Wein zum Abend mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Mhm.
Okay.
Leiden Ihre, jetzt würde ich einfach sagen, so wie das von mir,
stelle, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronische Erkrankungen
wie Zuckerkrankheit, Butterdruck.
Ja, Zucker hat von meinem Eltern ein kleiner, das hat sich nur bei mir irgendwie gezeigt.
Mhm.
Meine Eltern sind eigentlich so organisch relativ gesund.
Mein Vater hat ein bisschen Hüftprobleme.
Da ist geplant, dass er demnächst auf der linken Seite eine neue Hüfte kriegt.
Mhm.
Da hoffen wir, dass das alles gut geht.
Und meine Mutter hat natürlich ein Problem mit ihren Augen.
Mhm.
Das ist die Generation.
Also da muss sie regelmäßig behandelt werden.
Und das ist, glaube ich, auch ziemlich unangenehm.
Mhm. Okay.
Ja, okay.
Wie alt sind Ihre Eltern?
Ja, mein Vater ist 70.
Und meine Mutter ist 69.
Okay, 69.
Wie ist die Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Mhm. Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Ingenieurin.
Okay.
Ja, wer ist Ingenieurin?
Ich bin Bauingenieurin.
Bauingenieurin. Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstadt?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Okay.
Ja, wir haben zwei Söhne.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, gesund sind Sie schon.
Der Kleine, der macht mir so ein bisschen Sorgen.
Der ist so, der ist ziemlich spät jetzt auf die Welt gekommen.
Der ist noch ziemlich klein.
Und der hat ein bisschen Sprachprobleme, ja.
Der hat einen leichten Sprachfehler.
Und ja, das macht mir manchmal Sorgen,
dass der gehänselt wird im Kindergarten
oder in der Schule dann später.
Der stottert ein bisschen.
Ja, okay. Einverstanden.
Frage 1. Ich habe alle Fragen gesteckt.
Würdest du etwas hier zu fügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Na ja, was kann man jetzt dagegen machen?
Und wie kann man das vor allem verhindern,
dass ich wieder solche Schmerzen kriege?
Also, wenn diese Episode jetzt weg ist,
so etwas will ich ja nicht wieder erleben, dann?
Ja, es ist so für etwas genaues Sagen.
Sollte abgelöre ich brauche,
dann noch ein paar Untersuchungen,
wie körperliche Untersuchungen, rötchen- und blutunterzuchungen.
Ich denke, Sie haben Probleme mit Muskeln
und mit Landwirbelsäulen.
Ja, ich werde Sie erstmal körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde Sie erstmal körperlich untersuchen.
Und dann nehme ich Blut ab
und dann gebe ich Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel.
Also das wäre glaube ich gut.
Haben Sie denn etwas dagegen GRABIT?
Und du musst gut und relaxant zusammengeben.
Ah, okay.
Mhm, gut.
Ja, okay.
Okay, bitte warten Sie, ich rufe Sie gleich.
Gut, super.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Ich denke, einige wichtigsten Fragen hat nicht gestellt.
Nämlich, welche Frage hat sie nicht gestellt?
Auslöser.
Sie hat schon gesagt, Gartenarbeit und Schwerdentum aufheben.
Ich habe schwer gehoben, genau.
Ich habe Gartenarbeit gemacht und habe gebückt, gearbeitet und habe etwas Schweres hochgehoben.
Und Impfungen noch fehlt.
Ach ja, Impfungen fehlen noch, stimmt.
Ja, deswegen sind Sie schon einmal, ich habe einen anderen Arzt gewesen.
Sie haben gesagt, welche Beschwerden gehabt.
Ja, aber da bin ich ja nicht zum Arzt gegangen.
Das ist ja wieder weggegangen.
Und da bin ich nicht zum Arzt gegangen, nein.
Sie haben gesagt, gestern, nach der Arbeit auftreten, sind die Beschwerden.
Und im Laufe der Zeit, nur bei Bewegung verschlimmert.
Bei Positionsänderung sind sie besonders schlimm, die Schmerzen.
Im Laufe der Zeit verschlimmert, aber eigentlich sind sie konstant schlecht.
Konstant schlecht, okay.
Die Schmerzen, da wir hafta, oder gehen sie auch wieder weg, diese Frage.
Ne, ganz weg gehen die nicht.
Ja, okay.
Dein
Wahrscheinlich habe ich so vertrauenswürdig gewirkt, dass sie gar nicht gedacht hat, mich zu fragen.
Ist mir auch aufgefallen, denn diese Patientin hat tatsächlich in ihrer wilden Jugend mal haschisch geraucht.
Ja, sie hat mal grass geraucht.
Und ich denke, die Patientin hat diese Instruingeschichte nicht gut wissen, weil um 15 Uniteinheit eingenommen.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, dass sie 15 Einheiten spritzt am Tag.
Ich meine, Typ 1 Diabetes meines Lebens, von 10 Instruing, welche Dorf es gibt.
Ich habe neue Instruing, wie normal, weil ich so weit, ich weiß, gibt es 3 Mal,
für das wirkende Insulüschpiste und einmal lang wirkende Insulüschpiste.
Aber ich weiß nicht, heute sage ich, gibt es viele neue Instruingtype?
Nein, nein, nein, ich habe keine Veränderung.
Also da muss ich dazu sagen, das ist einer der neuen Fälle, die ich von einem Kollegen von ihnen aus München geschickt bekommen habe.
Dieser neue Fall ist aber genauso wie ein alter Fall, nur dass es da ein Mann war.
Und da war tatsächlich eine andere Aussage.
Da war eine Aussage, dass der als Kind bereits eben auch Diabetes hatte und dass er deswegen eine Insulinpumpe hat.
Ja.
Und dann ist man aus der Diskussion raus.
Bei dieser Patientin stand aber ausdrücklich, dass sie 15 Einheiten spritzt.
Zusätzlich zu Mikades.
Ja, sehr weniger.
Und das ist irgendwie ein bisschen komisch.
Ja, komisch.
Aber da sehen Sie wieder, ich bin kein Arzt, ja?
Ja, ja, ich.
Ich kann das nicht bewerten, ob da Quatsch steht in dem Fall oder nicht.
Ja, dann sagen wir, Patienten halt Insulinpumpe, dann sind wir auf der sicheren Seite.
Ja?
Okay.
Sie haben jetzt momentan Patienten, nicht Arzt.
Deswegen, Aische ist Arzt, erstens.
Muss sie fragen?
Mhm, mhm.
Okay, können wir Arstanskische anfangen, Aische?
Mhm, ja.
Okay.
Hallo, Oberarste.
Hallo.
Ich habe heute mit einer neuen Patientin gesprochen.
Ich wollte ja über diese Berichte.
Ja, erzählen Sie, was haben Sie gesehen?
Wen haben Sie gesehen?
Ja, die Patientin heißt Eva Haas.
Frau Haas ist 49 Jahre alt, geboren am 9.04.1974.
Sie haben heute seit gestern bestehende Rückwärtsweise.
Wie würden Sie das beim Fachbegriff nennen?
Ja.
Ja, Dunbarge.
Okay.
Dunbarge, ja, okay.
Dunbarge, ja, Dunbarge.
Okay.
Die Beschwerden sind gestern nach der Kartinarbeit besonders aufheblich eines,
besonders aufheblich des schweren Topf aufgetreten.
Nicht aufheblich des schweren Topfs.
Nach dem Aufheben eines schweren Topfes, ja.
Ja, nachdem aufheblich schweres Topf aufgetreten.
Und haben Sie sich im Räufe seit, besonders bei Positionänderung versteckt.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt auf einer Schmerzskolle.
Die Schmerzinschützler in unterer Rechte bein.
In der Rechte bein.
Entweder in das rechte Bein.
Ja, in das gesamte rechte Bein, bis wohin?
Ja, in der gesamte Rechte bein.
Die Einnahme von über Prof. Siksun, der 2-mal.
Und warme Kisten haben ja nicht geholfen oder teilweise Verwestung gebracht.
Die Patienten krackte über Hippohesthesi und Parästhesi.
Wo?
An der linken Beine.
Links? Nein.
Nein, nein, nein.
An der linken Beine bis kleinste.
Nein.
Nicht am linken.
Nein, nicht am linken.
Ich habe leichten getaucht, aber links.
Am Betroffenen.
Rechte Gezehshefte tut weh.
Und das ganze rechte Bein runter.
Ich denke, Frau Gehschelt.
Ganze Bein Hipposthesi, aber 5.
Seen Parästhesi.
Ja, genau.
Hat sie so gesagt.
Die klackte über Hippohesthesi am ganzer Rechte bein.
Und Parästhesi am 5. Seen.
Rechte.
Ja, 5. Rechte Seen.
Ja.
Die Frage nach früheren Englischen Beschwerden, FIBA,
ist es gut und fein.
Nein, Englische Beschwerden.
Ja, sie berichtete, dass sie früher Englische Rechte
Beschwerden gehabt hat.
In welchem Zusammenhang hat sie die Beschwerden gehabt?
Nach der Kartenaarbeiter.
Auch immer nach der Kartenaarbeiter,
so nach schwerer Arbeit.
Ja, ja.
Die vegetative Anamese ist unauffällig,
bis auf Insomnia wegen Beschwerden.
Bilehungun?
Ich sag, ich würde das in allergesagten,
als unverzweckert.
Nein, Bilehungun hat gezagten.
Ja, ist ihnen, ja,
ist ihnen, ja,
bei ihr ist eine Unverträglichkeit von Rohe
obstbekannt.
Obst und Gemüse, ne?
Obst und Gemüse.
Ja, bekannt.
Anvorerkrankungen.
Wie äußert sich die Unverträglichkeit?
Die sich durch die Bilehung oder
Metorismus äußert.
Seit 5 Jahren, Artiljahre-Hypertone.
Seit 7 Jahren Artiljahre-Hypertone.
7 Jahre, nicht 5 Jahre.
Okay, okay.
Hypertöne ist eine andere Artiljahre.
Sie ist ein
Verbrecher der
Hypertöne.
Sie hat eine
Operation behandelt.
Wie heißt das?
Sie ist allergisch auf
Penislin.
Sie ist
allergisch auf Penislin.
Sie ist allergisch auf
Penislin.
Penislin, der
zur Einrichtung muss.
Du musst auf
Sie ist Rauherrn seit Fürstinjaren zwei oder drei Zigaretten täglich.
Und die Trilke, die geregertet eingereist war.
Und der Vater, der Patientin, leide an Hüftprobleme.
Er wird bei ihm eine Totalendoprozess geplant.
Und die Mutter, der Patientin, leide an Makulade Generation.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht Makulade Generation, sondern anders.
Anders, ja, okay.
Das heißt Makulade Generation, das ist schon der Fachbegriff.
Die arbeitet als Bauingenieurin.
Die Mutter?
Was?
Die Patientin arbeitet als Bauingenieurin.
Sie ist verheiratet, hat zwei Söhne.
Die an amnestischen Angaben deuten amnestern auf eine Diskusprorapsis hin.
Welchen Bereich?
Lernen wir besäulebereit.
Was konnte das Differenzialdiagnostisch noch sein?
Die Harausgönigkeit könnte es sein, die muskulärspannung.
Aber das ist nicht ein Differenzialdiagnostisch, sondern nur Symptome.
Deswegen?
Ja, eine Fraktur bei der Danse, ja, eine Fraktur, ja.
Bei der Danse sollte es sein.
Ich habe noch eine Diagnose auf dem Zettel, was es noch sein könnte.
Sie hat ja erhebliche neurologische Ausfälle.
Ja, sehr viele Psyklerose.
Ach so?
Ich habe hier noch eine Spinalkanalschinoose.
Ja, Spinalkanalschinoose.
Also eine Fraktur oder Spinalkanalschinoose in Betra.
Ja, was machen Sie denn jetzt Diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ja, ich würde gerne erstmal körpärische Untersuchung.
Besonders neurologische Untersuchung.
Perifetan durch Brutmotorik sensibilität Untersuchung.
Ja, ich staste, ja erstmal ich staste...
Welche neurologischen Zeichen würden Sie denn abfragen oder testen?
Sensibilität, weil die Patientin über Taubheitsgütüren, die Poesterin,
dann prüfe ich die Reflexe und die Beweglichkeit der Gelenke.
Ja, aber es gibt ja auch so typische...
Ja, ja, typische Testzeichen.
Ja, lasseki sein oder?
Lasseki, Burudu...
Kernig habe ich noch.
Kernig, ja, kernig, kernig.
Was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Machen Sie überhaupt was?
Ja, Bulutbit, Bulutzuka, HBAAI-Sites.
Ja, weil die Diabetik errennt ist, ne?
Elektrolytas, Elektrolytas, Deberweite, Nierenweite.
Okay, gut. Also, Blut wird er abgenommen.
Und jetzt machen Sie Apparativverunterung?
Ich färme das erstmal, Rötchen, ja, in zwei Ebenen.
Was wird geröntcht?
Die Lendenwirbelsolle.
Ja, warum röntgen Sie?
Was schließen Sie aus damit?
Nicht uns bis fisch, aber bei Rötchen können wir Knochenvereinwürgen sehen.
Genau, sie können also...
Ja, ja, können wir auch praktisch...
Ja, genau, Deformationen können wir sehen.
Und wir können eine Fraktur sehen.
Das ist eine unserer Differenzialdiagnose.
Genau.
Er meinte, ich sei gut für die Knochenmuskeln sehen.
Und ja, Diskos für die Diskos.
Genau, dass wir sehen, ob da was eingeklemmt ist.
Genau, sehr gut.
Also wird die gute Frau auch noch in die Röhre kommen.
Ja, wenn sich jetzt Ihre Diagnose bestätigt,
was machen Sie denn für eine Therapie mit ihr?
Ja, erst mal eine Ergäte, Muskulerexen.
Und erfähle ich eine Krankengymnasie.
Ja.
Warme Kompression, z.B. Rot-Licht-Terep.
Oder kann ich eine minimalinvasive Injection, Cortison,
für die ja.
Genau, ja, genau.
Ich mache auch Orthopädikonsi.
Ja, genau.
Ja, da sollen die Orthopäben weiter gucken.
Ja, die Warschleimursurfern bildet sie oft zurück.
Ja, nach Therapie, ja.
Deswegen erfähre ich nicht,
dass ich eine Operation habe.
Also nicht direkt operieren,
sondern nur wenn alles andere nicht mehr funktioniert,
dann würde man die Bandscheibe operieren.
Ja, die Bandscheibe haben wir ja nicht umsonst,
die hat ja ihre Funktion eigentlich.
Gut, ja.
Gut, das war ja super.
Gut, dann informieren Sie mich bitte,
was aus Ihrer Patientin wirkt,
ob die Frau Haas wirklich im Vorfall hat.
Oder ob sie noch etwas anderes dahinter steckt.
Und ja, dann musst Sie aber nicht stationär bleiben,
oder, wenn wir nicht operieren müssen?
Ja, vielleicht.
Ja, muss man gucken, wie es geht.
Ja, nach der minimalinvasive Injection von Cortison.
Ja, da sollte sie erst mal da bleiben.
Ja, gut.
Okay, ja, sehr schön.
Gut.
Ja, Dr. Gündrich hat mehrfach interveniert,
haben Sie gemerkt, ja.
Und ich habe hin und wieder mal,
habe ich gemerkt,
wenn irgendeine Angabe nicht ganz genau stimmt,
passen Sie auch bei den Zahlen.
Geburtsdatum und alles ist super gelaufen.
Aber mit den, seit wieviel Jahren,
da wirklich genau hinhört,
das sind so Sachen, wo die Prüfer ja auch komisch sind.
Und das ist ganz witzig.
Bei dieser Datensammlung,
bei dieser Datensammlung aus München,
sind unheimlich viele Prüferfragen hinten dran.
Und das ist ganz merkwürdig,
die Prüfer fragen die unmöglichsten Sachen nach.
Die fragen also eben auch völlig außerhalb von diesem Fall.
Fragen Sie dann eben nach solchen Sachen.
Was ist die Patientin von Beruf?
Fragen Sie extra noch mal nach.
Dann haben Sie hier Augenblick,
was haben Sie noch gefragt?
Sie haben nicht nach weiteren Erkrankungen gefragt zwischendurch.
Die Frau hat zusätzlich noch etwas und nimmt auch noch ein weiteres Medikament.
Das haben Sie aber gar nicht weiter nachgefragt.
Sie hatte nämlich einen Hörsturz
und hat seitdem Antinitus und im Tebonin.
Und dann haben die Prüfer eben noch gefragt,
ja, wie wirkt Tebonin?
Dann haben Sie gefragt,
wie der Fachbegriff für Stottern ist.
Müßte ich jetzt wieder nachgucken.
Ich weiß es schon wieder nicht mehr.
Also ich denke mal, das ist hinfällig.
Aber die haben wirklich völlig idiotische Zeug gefragt.
Und ich glaube, das ist eine Münchnerspezialität.
Das habe ich jetzt von den anderen noch nicht so sehr gehört.
Aber es kommen immer wieder sehr schöne Begriffserklärungen da eigentlich drin vor.
Das ist schon ganz gut.
Wenn Ihnen ein Wort aus dem ganzen Gespräch Ihnen nicht klar ist,
schlagen Sie es nach oder fragen Sie.
Wenn wir hier zusammen sind, fragen Sie mich.
Wenn Sie sagen, ja, was bedeutet das denn?
Also ich sehe manchmal große Fragezeichen in den Augen.
Wenn ich einen Beruf nenne.
Hä? Was ist das denn?
Und dann ist es besser, wie Sie sprechen darüber,
als dass Sie überhaupt keine richtige Vorstellung haben,
was derjenige macht.
Und das kann ja auch durchaus wichtig sein.
So was.
Und ja, gut.
Ja, ich würde sagen, Fragen waren sich schön systematisch.
Und auch mit irgendeiner Sache ist mir aufgefallen.
Ja, Sie sagen ziemlich oft,
das ist ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal von Ihnen, glaube ich.
Sie sagen ziemlich oft, okay.
Und okay, bedeutet für Sie natürlich, habe ich verstanden.
Ja, ja, aber natürlich, wenn ich gerade sage,
dass ich irgendeine, dass ich irgendwelche Beschwerden habe,
oder dass mein Kind ein Problem hat, ja,
dann ist das natürlich nicht okay.
Ja, ich suche gleich.
Das ist etwas, was den Patienten belastet.
Und da sollte man das sagen, ich habe verstanden.
Ja, so. Aber okay, klingt dann so, ja, ist super, ne?
Und das passt natürlich nicht so gut.
Okay, gut, das war okay.